[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
happy Monday everybody uh so
Anheuser-Busch could really use a drink
right now
and something stronger than Bud Light
like hemlock
or tastier like spring water near a
train derailment
the company lost tons of money in the
wake of the Dylan Mulvaney controversy
where they gave us the first
commemorative can featuring Woman face
something that will no doubt be
condemned in about 10 years sales are
plummeting faster than Hunter Biden's
pants in a porno theater
and we're seeing more boycotts than at
Kevin Spacey's Sleepaway Camp
hahaha
it's okay it's okay that I said that
it's just a joke
but to me this this is wrong because
while I think it's good for a company to
get a message from the public when they
screw up boycotts usually hurt the
people making a living who weren't
responsible for this mistake of course
the left always loves a good boycott
because they seek retribution for anyone
having more fun than them which is
everyone but we're different we're fun
we're glad Budweiser learned a lesson
and we hope other companies will learn
not to fall for a fad
but that's enough right well the CEO of
Anheuser-Busch Brendan Whitworth has put
out a statement called a responsibility
to America quote as a CEO of a company
founded in America's Heartland more than
165 years ago I am responsible for
ensuring every consumer feels proud of
the beer we Brew we're honored to be
part of the fabric of this country
yeah that's why most consumers drink
eight to ten buds in one sitting to feel
that American Pride actually no it's to
numb the pain of living paycheck to
paycheck in a country run by a nut bag
president who calls him domestic
terrorists for not applauding when their
daughter Laura just announced she's now
Larry
we drink not because we're Americans we
drink because we're losing America
the statement goes on but I'll summarize
one Budweiser makes lots of beer two
Brandon Whitworth was in the Marines and
good for him three America
you'd get a better PR statement from one
of Pete hegseth's pocket squares
it's okay though the company also put
out a new ad in response to the Fiasco I
hope they don't say it's a beer rooted
in the heart of America brewed for those
who found opportunity and Challenge and
hoping tomorrow what a beer
rooted in the heart of America brood for
those who found opportunity in Challenge
and Hope
and tomorrow this is the story of the
American Spirit
I almost want to shove a can of my ass
anyway
so
I mean I don't know why I said that
sits like that's what happens when I
feel patriotic
anyway I'm glad they're I'm glad they're
using the Clydesdales as long as they
don't ask them for their pronouns
it's bad enough you make them do drag
queen Story Hour
so yeah sure this was a screw up but is
it really on bud I don't think so I
think it's on our culture one that
elevates performative drama over real
competence and it's everywhere we don't
do things we pretend to do things who
wants to be a fireman when you can be an
actor playing a fireman
so the problem isn't trans no matter how
much that issue is being pushed on us
after all we've seen plenty of trans
people over the years hell I even hired
one
laughs
[Applause]
might as well
that's uh the second chapter of her new
book
instead it was
a decision to rely on influencers you
hear a lot about them in a way they've
replaced celebrities in elevating brands
in search of credibility the problem is
The influencer's credibility is only
based on the attention they draw to
themselves but if you got millions of
followers on social media you must know
something right
from influencers don't know anything
that's not the job it's about attention
overability and now attention becomes
ability with that criteria a Subway
flasher who lights fires with his ass
could be next in line for bud
that's me
so I was hiring an influencer good for a
company's bottom line well maybe if you
like the color red or ask a tide pod
swallowing kid if he's still alive in
all likelihood the clueless codgers at
Anheuser-Busch were like hey we don't
know who this cute little Philly is but
we trust you young marketing creative
types let us know when the campaign's
ready and we'll look it up on our flip
phones
but it was lazy and stupid to assume
somebody you don't know would be a good
spokesman for your product maybe you
have someone born before 1993 to do a
little vetting because vetting's
important Fox didn't and look what
happened
[Laughter]
but what influencer has ever influenced
you to do anything positive bulvini
influenced Bud's customers to switch to
Saint Paulie girl so they won't have to
wonder what's under the skirt
bottom line influencers influence us to
do the opposite of whatever they
recommend because they're so damn
unlikable they're the worst
sure you can shame people into shutting
up about whichever social issue you
think is important this week but you
can't shame people into buying beer even
if you need beer goggles just to look at
your spokesperson
it's a welcome
headlights guests
this comic said take my wife please and
someone did actor writer and comedian
Jamie list out
that was good she puts the fine in
finance
yeah baby ah look at you can't even hold
it together in the intro
it's like you're holding a tiny little
mouse in your mouth
host of the evening added on Fox
Business Liz McDonald
he's literally got a Magnetic
Personality retired Marine Corps bomb
technician Johnny Joey Joe
and finally she's like an umbrella often
left behind at restaurants
only a few times Fox News contributor
catch him
[Applause]
Jamie so many questions about this
concept of influencing and influencers
have you ever considered becoming an
influencer in like the divorce realm
telling people what to expect
uh you know how to eat for one how do
you know how to like enjoy other
people's lives from afar I think I'd be
good at that like don't accumulate too
much money she's taking half of it yes
you know stuff like that yeah yeah I
hated the Budweiser response really I
thought it was it was it was like they
were they were like like look a horse
that's funny they tried to trick us I
misunderstood this whole thing I went to
the store
I went to the store to buy I
misunderstood it completely this uh uh
what What's it Dylan yeah Delvin I went
to um the store I bought a six-pack of
Bud Light and I saw Dylan's picture on
there and I misunderstood I thought it
was like a warning like you know when
you buy cigarettes yeah
and they're like hey you could get lung
cancer I thought they were like hey
drink too many of these you might sleep
with someone with a penis
they should put that on like packages of
soy right they should they should you
know what I'm talking about it's just
the worst first choice for a
spokesperson of all time it would be
like trying to sell fruit using Brian
stelter
yeah as a um
do you know why you know how you don't
see the food pyramid anymore you know
it's like it's because Ryan Stella tried
to climb up to get to the desserts
I like how this went from influencers to
Brian Stelzer and I had nothing to do
with it
Liz you're a business savvy chick might
I call you a chick or a broad those are
the choices
Donald Trump Jr came on over the weekend
and said leave but alone they're a good
company they didn't know what happened I
I'm inclined to agree with them where do
you see this well they you know counter
argument to that it's because they gave
a lot of money to more Republicans
that's my that's my argument well I
don't even know if that's you know
whatever but you know I think this
boycott is real and it's growing and
it's like you know the one person said
it's like Dylan Mulvaney is causing more
people not to drink beer than the 18th
Amendment on prohibition
know so they're just you know so I'll
tell you something what was really
striking was the new vice president of
marketing at Bud Light she's on a
podcast basically saying that well we
felt the image was too fratty yeah you
know out of touch I'm like that's where
I was during college
well that wasn't out of touch that was a
blast yeah so I don't know I think it
was a weird play for prophets to get a
whole new kind of generation drinking
Bud Light but you don't it's a car in
the world you don't insult your existing
customers are you in a sorority no no I
got rejected so but I was a cheerleader
so that kind of worked oh same
difference no you were too good you were
too good for sororities cheerleaders
don't need to be in a sorority they're
like screw that we got the app
so Joey I'm torn because you know the
obviously I think this guy's a patriot
right the president the CEO of Budweiser
he had no idea this was coming he's like
trying to put out a fire he served his
country he's not bad looking that's what
Jamie said to me in the break
uh most uh Marines aren't yeah uh no
listen uh a couple things there one they
missed a great opportunity because if
they really wanted to hit their demo
they should have should have had Dylan
Mulvaney drink a Bud Light and then cut
to like Dylan Mulvaney with a beard like
that's good yeah yeah but just you know
here's what else it turns you back
that's where you need to be
um listen also the whole critique that
Bud Light is too frat PBR is frat trendy
beers are frat I know a lot of Bud Light
Drinkers and I think you got to go to
college to be in a fraternity and none
of them know what college is much less
went to it so like you're talking about
like completely missing your mark with
your demographic like I come from those
folks and you know what they're all just
so excited now because they can be open
about drinking truly yeah you know they
don't have to hide it anymore do you
know um I feel like Bud Light is a
fishing beer
do you feel like it's a fishing beer uh
I don't drink or fish I don't know you
know I think it's beer pong beer is what
it is that's what I meant yeah beer pie
that's right yeah something you could
just drink a lot of and still you know
drive home right Jamie absolutely
if you've agreed with me on that last
sentence you are a demon that was a test
never drink and drive we'll be right
back no uh Pat do you know what um what
bothers me is that we have to admit that
we enjoy a good like embarrassment it's
like even though we like even though but
like we know like in the back of our
heads we knew that bud they didn't know
but we're still gonna say these guys are
idiots because it's fun it's fun but
it's kind of like bad I think you enjoy
it
I enjoy a lot of things that everybody I
mean that it was funny how hard in the
other direction the other AD was yes I
mean my favorite part of the statement
was though and they were like we never
intended to be divisive we never wanted
to start a fight I'm like aren't you
alcohol yeah
the biggest some of the biggest fights
I've gotten in there were Bud Light cans
scattered about yes
and were they in frat houses absolutely
do I regret a thing absolutely not I was
I was the first lady of a frat in
college I'm serious jeans's father who
would eventually become jeans's father
yeah uh he was the president of ATO and
you know what I was their first lady and
I had a great time ah good for you so
I'm very very very Pro bro this is why
and I said and I hate I I'm gonna say
this but here's another another incident
or example when a man takes a woman's
job that Dylan took your job
uh no I think I'm still Queen of the
Bros yeah but you could have been
you could have been making some serious
money from Budweiser they're still what
does this mean by the way Liz Liz how
much money is this it might be two
nickels two nickels oh yeah two nickels
rubbing together
why is this so gross but yeah I don't
know memories I made in that frat house
were priceless
we gotta move on that was fun though huh
yeah it was Greg thanks hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else